i think your documentary is going to be
huge in
so many ways it's so interesting because
you have a behind-the-scenes look
of what all the people we grew up
around uh you know whether it's a
leonardo dicaprio and a balthazar getty
and a david arquette
and i mean how were we not hanging out
together at that time we were kids
friends when we were kids i don't know
how we weren't together
i have no idea i don't know i know like
one minute i'm like oh there's corey
feldman and alfonso ribeiro
and then i'm like wait there's our cat
and like vault
so so much love throughout it was so
great to be able to sit down and talk to
my
dear friend so i grew up with brian
greene and stephen dorff and you know
and all of these childhood friends
balthazar getty
who of course is like still my family i
mean these
these really these friendships are are
more like
family than than anything so many of the
people
that have been lost and and are no
longer with us
are also in the documentary like rodney
harvey
oh my gosh rodney harvey rodney oh
and then of course friends like jonathan
brandes who was such a big part of my
life and
and then passed away so young and justin
pearson just all of these
amazing people that were such important
pivotal parts of my life
yeah the documentary really shows
the journey of you know where these
people were
at before they were taken away from us
and people do not have that window like
you
had so it's really extraordinary to be
a fly on the wall and see these people
but that you do it without frivolity you
do it with
a very thought-provoking writer
director's
lens of asking yourself you know
are we aware of what our friends are
going through
i agree a thousand percent and the
realization in watching these videos
back
you know i remembered our lives being so
full of life and love and joy
and then i had lost some of my best
friends so early on
and so i always wondered if things had
happened the way i remembered them and i
think it was almost
a subconscious thing that i locked it
all away in a vault and didn't open it
for decades
and then watching the tapes back and
realizing how many of us
were going through different stages of
pain and not
seeing it and and and something that
really
rings so true to me is that there was an
authentic
love between us you know i mean that we
really did have
these very deep relationships and i
think that was one of the reasons that
the losses
were felt so deeply because these
weren't superficial relationships these
were people
that there was these deep connections
with
so that's what i'm talking about that's
perspective
that's a perspective i can get behind i
just
i love it uh but yeah oh here's a weird
one
you uh your your boyfriend from house of
pain i remember going out on a date
with eric everlast you did yes and he
put a cassette tape
in my car um
oh that's so high and played the song
that was their new single
and it was jump around okay that is
i mean that is a really slick move i
mean
eric that i mean that's a very cool move
to play the new
the the new demo well it's so funny
so here so we would have hung out
together because like danny and i i mean
that would have been like the power uh
the power uh double couple
yeah i know eric and i went on like one
date and one day only but i remember him
playing this demo tape for me and i was
like
this song is gonna be an anthem big
i love it you know it's it's so amazing
and i i think about
friends like michael rap report who who
and brian and just
how many of my old friends have been
so supportive throughout this project
the amazing
leo whom i love so much with with all my
heart you know
and and just the ways in which friends
have rallied around has been
just such an inspiration to me and i met
leonardo dicaprio through none other
than sarah
gilbert who's of course sarah gilbert
here in the documentary
i love sarah so much one of my favorite
moments is when she's like oh you're
gonna have so many hours of boring
footage on that video camera it's
one of my all-time favorite moments and
then the incredible linda perry who
did such an incredible beautiful score
whom
i love so much yeah your documentary
opens up with pearl jam
like eddie better i mean my my friend
eddie and jill
came came in and i mean just amazing
artist and trent rezner
you know gave us a song and cranberries
i mean
really everyone rallied around and
it was so incredible to see that support
and of course the incredible sean who
has just been amazing throughout well i
really did live such a parallel life to
yours and
and we were you know god we were at the
white house at the same time probably
doing
just say no campaigns totally completely
and by the way for the record
i did the just say no drug to drugs
campaign it was before i was partying i
mean everyone's like were you partying
and that that was like no i was it was a
few years later
i had partied was not partying and then
went back to partying but like we were
kicking it with the reagans at the white
house
completely i remember like my mom losing
me and finding me and i was like
literally hanging out
in the oval office with my like legs up
like i mean not that that did not come
out right i had my feet kicked up
and i was eating like i was eating fried
chicken
because like my mom couldn't find me
also you have a punky
brewster reboot which is so
fun punky power forever the punky
brewster reboot has been
i don't want to say reboot i call it a
continuation because it doesn't feel
like a reboot it feels like a
continuation
and it's that superhero that i love to
lean into
the punky within all of us and all 10
episodes of the new
continued hunky brewster are streaming
now
on peacock i love you so much
i love you so much thank you for giving
everyone
this incredible window into your journey
that everyone watching is going to
marvel at
it's kid 90. it's streaming exclusively
now
on hulu i love you
[Music]
you